meine lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einer runde logos erraten
mit sandra bullock
meine wohnung
nicht immer lässt was ist dein das ist
www
ad-hoc-news
de sind wie geschaffen dafür
aber die punkte nicht
dass die ihr wollt ich hab's alleinigen
ist handwerk
okay was dann
guck mal da ist
und wir das ja
ich kenne die begriffe nicht so schnell
kommen gib mir mal zehn sekunden
vorsprung okay ihr fast sisikon
vorsprung guck mal da ist
fortuna düsseldorf oder köln
[Musik]
nein
nein nein nein nein klasse ist darf
die dinge
getan
ich rate komplett kümmern
das ist maria zur kundenpflege
nein
das ist mein gott ist das thema
leid
lidl oder sowas tb haben
das ist
dieser dringend mittel bestellt ist
lukasz piszczek machte so wie ein alter
opa ob du kannst deinen kopf kann
spender vorgestreckt
nur weil du keine angst
ich hab wirklich kein arzt
bereit
das meint ja du kannst du können wir
schaffen die reha programm ist mein
zweiter ist der erste katalog es gibt
keinen grund das 20 die logen
also punkte nicht guck mal da ist
kommen
[Musik]
cocoa beach
cartoon network
was ist denn das cartoon network cartoon
entbrennt sind dafür hätte ich kann ich
nicht
wir werden
auf
[Musik]
ihn so
alt er mein laden junge guckt
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein gott ich musste es einfach nicht
gesagt bin ich tun ja ich habe das
gesehen ich es einfach nicht gesagt guck
mal da ich
[Musik]
nein das ist wichtig doch nein nein sie
sich erzählt das nicht wirklich des
paid my dues kann ist dass diese
seltsame google is back ich hab die
vorherigen das ja das
ach so ja aber das muss ich dass wir das
auch betreiben
warum inhalte gehen wiederholung vom
haben wir immer wieder hunger
[Musik]
nokia so
spezialität
keiner kommt das so
wenn man se wegnimmt ist das was ich bin
ja du bist böse
böse kanada
[Musik]
hamburg bis zu tun das ist
ja
das ist rheinland-pfalz
guck mal da ist
dass es nicht schneller brauchen heißt
nicht
dass man nur wenn man süchtig ist
[Musik]
bist du mit der klinke
was der zeitung
[Musik]
ich sag
kein plan
und sms die tirol steine aber das kmg
und
mein gott ist das wichtiger meister das
ist am ende
[Musik]
das ist otto
nein das leben das ist über zwei
stockwerke dass das ist apollo optik
[Musik]
nein-stimmen josé carlos
pace
er war schneller
ich habe das gesagt ich hab's
erkenntnis
von unserem podcast
nein ich lukas podolski mangal das ist
nicht was das bedeutet
zeigt sandra immer zuerst das
stimmt
[Musik]
sylvester stallone
sony ericsson ja
[Musik]
das ist
das habe ich noch nie gesehen doch ich
habe das auch schon mal gesehen aber
[Musik]
spardosen
sparkasse emsland
ja ich hab mich geguckt ich auch nicht
[Musik]
im paket
motorrad aber nicht die hl
wie hält es den weg sodass umgehen indem
sie das dann auch sofort mein gott
[Musik]
extra so wenig track das ist nicht
direkt das ist dieses jahr
die sind los ging lief über dich
verschickt niemand war so halte leute
verschicken darüber nein das ist wie
heißt denn jemanden gehen
das ist
wie heißt das denn
du bist das heißt oder nicht vergessen
[Musik]
also das was du gesagt jetzt schon mit
der ersten stimme aber richtig
wir sehen hier mal den punktestand
eingeblendet wir sind immer schon mal
den wieder angeschrieben damit
begonnen und sich gefreut als hier
gut auskennt im global mich selber so
sage
viel spaß beim tanzen kennen